[Music]
foreign
oh
I hope folks are well
my day's been
all right
I think
I don't know it
I had annoying things go wrong towards
the very end of the day and my usual not
getting as much done as I would like
which
it's
it's kind of standard for me regardless
of how much I get done
I don't know I feel like there were some
days
I would look back and go I got a lot
done it's just
been a while
oh well
hey everybody
hope uh hope everyone is doing well
um
you like the top thank you uh Meg gave
me this
uh actually
ah
excuse me
some days I need to point out to me this
yes as you as you are very very well
aware Carolyn got to do an interview
with Joseph lid lidster on the awful lot
of running podcasts
he said not bragging that's awesome
I also don't know who that is but I'm
going to assume it's a big deal
and that's very cool
I've been vetching about chocolate and
stocks so there was my day
I mean
chocolate's great but
most chocolate is produced by absolute
monsters and uh stocks are one of the
stupidest aspects of the made up thing
that is money so yeah
uh
your high your hydration is Pinot Grigio
my hydration is Unified press by citizen
cider they make
very good water
I checked with U.S Postal Service Jesse
genders received my little gift for her
that's great I'm actually I'm really
annoyed
because I got I got her something that I
had intended to give her
for Christmas
and I have not been able to find where
in the hell I put it
so hopefully I can find it before her
birthday and send it for that
uh
it's really irritating
uh he wrote broken for Torchwood oh I've
reviewed broken recently that was
actually that that one was really good I
like that one
uh big Finish Master he wrote episode
Sarah Jane Torchwood cool cool cool cool
nice
you doubt it site why would you doubt
its cider
why would you doubt that
you're very strange sometimes
if I want to keep watching I really
should not be drinking any liquid at all
right now well you know there's
downsides to every contingency
squirrel brain yeah
yeah
Christmas was just like a few days ago
right it's fine yeah I know that's
that's what I thought
for a while and then
ah
I saw your short I wish there was
something I could do oh the um the one
from yesterday
um because I I put up another short
today which is getting far less traction
just because it's just talking about
some
MCU related news so
I doubt everything you drink and I take
being called strange as a compliment
well I do too normally I just like
I mean they're the most straightforward
way I really don't know what to make you
sometimes I'm devastating you didn't
like Bicentennial Man I
Bicentennial Man is one of those videos
where
I didn't expect to get the pushback that
I got
there are a few In Bruges probably the
biggest one
um where like I knew it was a well-liked
movie but I didn't realize that it had
psychotic fans
um and I there's a shockingly large
amount of comments defending
star chaser
on that video
it's weird that like no matter what a
thing is somebody will defend it in and
of itself that's fine if you liked it
that's great but like
people got mad at me for not liking
Bicentennial Man and people who really
got mad at me for not liking him Bruges
oh did people get pissed at me not
liking In Bruges
uh yeah had the leverage review go up
earlier that was a fun show I would like
to find the time
to uh watch more of that
I don't have the time but I'd love to
find it uh
I read the B gay Duke Comics Anthology
and surprisingly enjoyed it I have not
heard of that but I like the title
yeah I don't care about much about the
Punisher and the MCU see I didn't get
into this because I only had 60 seconds
for the short but like
John Bernthal is the third best Punisher
we've had
so you know I'm not
I'm not super excited you know about the
idea
Bicentennial Man wasn't the best movie
but it was Robin Williams so we'll
always have a special place with me like
I
held you for it I guess what I what I
get
I I guess I've just reached enough of a
point myself that I recognize that my
nostalgic level of something does not
make it above criticism and I guess it
throws me off when other people
um aren't there
we're like they very clearly have a deep
love from the first time they saw it and
I'm like that's fine you can still like
it nostalgic love is love but like
I I'm not going to share that I'm sorry
uh
love Ron Williams and Morgan Mindy I
mean I like drum Williams a lot
um
I'm not sure how many of his
movies hold up as movies
like he's a great presence he always he
always was but
like I think good morning Vietnam holds
up pretty well
um Good Will hunting's fine I always
thought that got a little overpraised
um Aladdin holds holds up well
but
I I you know what one I need to rewatch
I need to re-watch World's Greatest Dad
see if that holds up as well as my
memory of it is
yeah I should revisit that one
I don't get why you call your reviews
rambling if anything they're very
concise largely it's just my way of
indicating that they're not scripted and
I usually don't even have notes
uh
we should have known known who Jake
Harris when Robin Williams begged to
play Hagrid and she refused well she
refused I mean like I'm not disagreeing
with you but like she refused because
she was super insistent on all UK cast
which
I can respect
like I'm not incapable of respecting
some of the things she's done over her
life I just have no respect for her as a
human being at this point in time you
know
what do I think of the amalgam Comics
between Marvel and DC those are weird
I've got an issue I think I've got issue
one of dark claw the one that was the
mashup of Wolverine and Batman
I never got around to reviewing that
back when I did 90s Comics free trial I
should have
never got around to it
Jumanji Jumanji
Jumanji I have nostalgic love for I
don't think it holds up especially well
I mean it holds up it has the it has the
issue of being a 90s family movie which
not a Great era of quality for family
movies if we are being completely honest
but it's also a you know heavily reliant
on
special effects that
did not age well at all
Patch Adams was apparently disliked by
the real Patch Adams but the movie still
kind of sparked my interest in being a
hospice nurse well I can still do good
but yeah the real Patch Adams hey he did
that and like to be fair his main thing
was one specific
thing because so I I actually
um
kind of find this interesting
so
um
the
the aspect of the movie that he really
took that the real Patch Adams really
took objection to
so there's the bit in the movie where
his friend uh she lets this guy into the
clinic kind of after hours and he
he's a very unsettled individual and he
kills her the thing is that really
happened
but it wasn't a woman and it wasn't
potential love interest it was a guy it
was one of his male friends and he found
it really offensive
that they changed it to this made-up
woman you know potential theoretical
love interest who wasn't real
and I don't blame him for that
yet Lord of the Rings uh films use
actors from many countries I don't think
that's a fair comparison since wow Lord
of the Rings is based heavily on
um you know mythology Cur you know
cripped from Europe in general but a lot
of UK influences and of course
um told uh Tolkien himself being from
there like it's also a made-up place
they can fudge accents whereas Harry
Potter is literally meant to be set in
the UK I I don't I don't think that's a
valley comparison
um the fundamentals of the world are not
the same
well I say not a valid comparison on
that specific issue I mean obviously
overall you want to compare the two
compare the two
uh Mrs Doubtfire was a great movie it's
okay uh
[Music]
the thing with
um
Mrs Doubtfire is it's an okay movie
my issues with it have a lot to go have
a lot to do with how it fits into what
was a very long-running
Trope in depictions of men who dress as
women which keep in mind I identified as
a CIS male cross-dresser for a long damn
time but it really bothered me that
those things were always constructed to
a always be comedies because it was
inherently thought to be laughable and B
it was always circumstance that forced
them into that
you know
Tootsie it's the only way he's going to
get work is to pretend to be a woman
um Some Like It Hot they have to hide
from the mob so they have to pretend to
be women Mrs Doubtfire he it's the only
way he's going to get close to his kids
so he has to pretend to be a woman
there's just
at this point in time I have an
I have an inherent
with anything that fits the mold of well
the only obviously the only reason a man
would ever dress like a woman is if
circumstances forced him to no guy would
ever just do it
and obviously this sounds like an odd
thing for me to complain about given
that I no longer identify as a man but
you know
I still find that unhelpful
and that was super ubiquitous
as a thing for decades and
[Music]
Mrs Doubtfire is technically illegal to
show in some places in the US Now isn't
it I don't think so because I think
like the Tennessee law only
applies to live performance I do not
believe it is written it's badly written
do not get me wrong it is a horribly
broadly written thing it effectively
Outlaws pride and
um if a cop felt like being a dick
you could probably find a reason to just
arrest any
um visibly gender queer person just for
being out in public
um by claiming well what you were doing
constitutes performance
so
um as badly written as that is I'm
pretty sure that it is only live
performance
but yeah
favorite narrator for an audiobook
you've listened to uh Douglas Adams
narrating uh The Hitchhiker's Guide to
the Galaxy books
love it it's amazing
uh let's see
what about the Doubtfire musical I keep
forgetting that that's being made I like
can we
uh I get why they do it it makes big
money and it's easier to sell
it's easier to sell
uh tickets to a big stage musical thing
for a thing that is a name they already
recognize but like can we stop
can we stop
like they're they're doing mean they're
doing a movie version of The Mean Girls
musical which is a musical version
of a movie that all exists like we I put
up with that for the producers I didn't
want to become a freaking Trend
Supremo Mega I missed your Super Chat
earlier on 2000's Marvel thoughts on the
event Civil War by Mark Miller it
started trying to Super of Heroes
fighting other heroes in big massive
crossovers it did not start that Trend
at all that is a long and proud
Tradition at Marvel may I introduce you
to the concept of Secret Wars
started the 80s now granted that wasn't
necessarily Hero's fighting Heroes but
that was big massive crossover and
heroes fighting Heroes for any number of
reasons from misunderstandings to mind
control to whatever else like it's got a
lot of precedent in Marvel
Civil War was a um
particularly big swing at trying to do
that I actually haven't read it
start to finish yet
however
um it actually has been on the review
docket back burner for a while uh I do
need to get to that eventually I've been
putting that one off because
it's big it's a big event and obviously
I can't get an audiobook version of that
so I can't use the shortcut I usually
like to use for books so
I love The Birdcage but really dislike
the Sun for pushing his dad to play
straight in hide album oh yeah so that's
the thing about that was the thing about
re-watching the birdcage as an adult the
sun is a
he's a terrible person he's awful and
the movie doesn't seem to recognize that
which is frustrating
uh
uh I'm really enjoying quillen's sword I
love how Wisp and a new I don't take
crap off the NPCs I really enjoy playing
wisp
um a lot knit and crochet tiger it's
yeah
that I'm I I've loved doing that DND
campaign a lot do I like Aladdin I do I
haven't re-watched Aladdin in ages but I
like it
so
uh uh Black cover I Black cover asked
how is Liz
um
Liz and I uh are no longer together we
split
uh on the tail end of last year
um I think I mentioned this at a
previous
stream
but yes Liz and I are
um are not Partners any longer so that
that would be the reason why
hot take I love Neil Gaiman stories I do
not like his narration style I've
enjoyed his narration because I'm I'm
currently I've started on um for when
I'm in the car I've started on
uh Sandman Act 2 and I like his
narration
personally I think it works well granted
I like it I you know he's not having to
do like characters but just to hear him
describe things I like his voice for
that
and Hairspray the movie The Musical too
yeah that one too
uh if you think that's a stretch to make
into a musical they just did Great
British Bake Off The Musical
ah
anyway
listening to the audiobook of her
majesty Secret Service I know he's doing
uh the voice so it'd be funny if I
argued he's the best James Bond
uh interesting
being a terrible person makes it easier
to marry into a republican family I
guess that's true that's another aspect
of that we don't really think about
John vinyls
thank you very much for the Super Chat
even if the films and shows of phase
four have been inconsistent at times
that's being generous the lack of need
to build up to a giant Avengers
crossover allowed for a lot of creative
freedom and ambition
I don't
I don't think I agree
there was a lot of hampered ambition
like
I would say the most creative thing that
was allowed to happen
was probably She-Hulk and that really
didn't pull together until the the back
end
um but I look at a lot of the rest of
what happened and honestly a lot of it
feels very safe with like here's the one
slightly out of the box thing we're
allowing
cause like
like maybe it's not fair to compare
um Multiverse of Madness to everything
everywhere all at once but like
I'm going to if only for the purposes of
pointing out
one shows the full breadth of what you
can do with the Multiverse and the other
did almost nothing with it
I I don't like it could have it could
have
led to a lot of creative freedom and
ambition
and you can see if you boil down some of
the things that were made down to the
basic components you could see how that
seed could have been creative and
ambitious they weren't allowed to be
though
I I think phase four is really kind of a
wash
uh let's see
love your video on the Sandman series
thank you
uh so has
uh elity young done something that would
means you you wouldn't be as bad as
electrode not that I know of
I I won't lie I just really
really
didn't like her Electra now granted odds
are that was more writing problem than
her but I thought she and Charlie Cox
had no chemistry whatsoever
like none
so no she didn't do anything back
she didn't do anything bad that would
prevent her from coming back
but
uh
like I've Electra
I thought Elektra was the worst single
worst thing in the entire Marvel Netflix
thing and I say that having watched both
seasons of Iron Fist
I really I I really hate it I really
hated Elektra
I regret I haven't watched more Quinn
store my backlogs are so backed up I get
that but I cover I get that
hairsprays coming to town but crowds are
still a tricky thing here yeah they can
be hairspray's a fun show it I yeah I
could see that on Broadway with George
Wendt which was that was delightful
I was wondering if you ever watched the
Netflix post-apocalypse comedy called
Daybreak I've been watching for the past
couple hours it's pretty damn funny I
have not
Jeffrey so uh nope can't answer you on
that one
I left out the word tenants somehow I
did wonder who you were referring to Ben
but okay I got you now tenant doing the
narration for Honor emergency Secret
Service and so it would be funny if I
said he's the best Bond
I mean if you want to give a super
hipster answer sure start going for it
speaking of bond did you hear that the
books are being censored censored or
updated because they're that's there's a
difference a lot of books lately have
been getting updates on language
phrasing and things like that that's not
the same thing as censorship
um like my classic example of that is my
favorite Agatha Christie book is and
then there were none
which wasn't always called that it was
originally called Ten Little Indians
before that it was called ten little
something I will not say on stream
because it would get me banned so like
that's not censorship
that's making it so that it is still
accessible to a modern audience
I don't consider that to be censorship
especially considering like whenever
they do that they archive the old
versions it's not like they burn them
John vinyls once again thank you very
much if the Owl House season 3 hadn't
been crushed into three specials what
things in them would have been running
plot threads throughout the season and
what would have been one episode plot
Beats
um well I think
short version is what we've seen so far
probably would have comprised the a
story of at least
uh I'd say eight episodes and then you'd
get B stories out of side stuff going on
with Adalia and um with v and stuff like
that like a lot of that gets crushed
down and has to be glossed over but
that's the main thing I I don't feel
like the central story is that much
different and it's just like taking time
out to give a side character a focus
episode is what we're missing and I am
missing that I like those characters but
Supreme Omega back again thank you very
much do you feel writers never allowed
Aunt May to die is another sign of Peter
stagnation because he couldn't have a
kid and has marriage a race to anime I
I don't know what the hell
writer's issue with just lighting Aunt
May die is well now I do it's um
it's just another it's just another
iteration of
um
these stories were food you're refusing
to move forward and to maintain the
status quo at all times and at all costs
which is a like I've I've got a video
coming out on the MJ thing
next week
I think next week
let me check my schedule I can't
remember now
I can't like I swear I cannot remember
anything anymore
no this week it's this week
next week's the other thing
um
yeah so yeah I have to edit that
tomorrow actually
um so
um but yeah it
I don't think it's because they're like
Aunt May is such a beloved character I
think it's just because
if we can't reset him back to the status
quo of caring for Aunt May and you know
we can't let them have a kid and we
can't we can't let things move forward
ah it's really annoying am I seeing
Scream Six nah
last scream I saw was three
and I've heard some of the newer ones
are good I don't doubt that they are but
ah
uh what do I think about your new name
Julia Rowell I did see that I did see
that I like it I see what you did there
um
how far am I into Wednesday I have two
episodes to go I'm actually gonna
hopefully finish that off
um later tonight
yeah
I'm on episode four of the last of us I
hope you are enjoying it
um Pirates
let's see here
can we talk about the audacity of the
screenwriters Guild award letting Mark
Wahlberg be one of the be the one to
present best Ensemble price to a group
of
predominantly Asian actors
I mean
I don't know what there is to talk about
because for
I don't I don't think the SAG Awards are
as closely guarded as like the Oscars
but as a rule with these things they
don't they set up the presenters they
don't know who's going to win
I mean they don't or they're not
supposed to at least so you know the
people arranging the show and who's
presenting and who's doing what they
don't know who's going to come up and
accept it
should maybe they have taken it into
consideration as to the possibility I
don't know maybe but like that was not a
that was not manufact that was not a
situation manufactured on purpose I
don't believe that
I Gotta See assassins on Broadway with
Neil Patrick Harris ooh very nice
excuse me how do I feel about AI art
books videos
uh referring to the recent from the
corridor crew I don't know Corridor crew
the AI thing overall here's
I wish we could kind of just skip to
whatever the ends is gonna be
because right now there's so much crap
up in the air like who owns it
does the person who gave the AI the
prompt
own it does the programmer who designed
the AI own it do the Creative people
whose work was
scoured and imitated
should they own it since the algorithm
basically stole their artistic voices
and repurpose them
it's a mess and I kind of want to jump
to the end and not
have to deal with the messy middle which
is odd because whenever I write I pretty
much always deal with the messy middle
but like
while that's a rich venue for
storytelling it's a pain in the
to live in
I would love for Miles Morales to have a
TV show of his own
yeah
I'll be fine
was this a fever dream or was Sony
really going to do an Aunt May
Spider-Man prequel oh they were really
gonna do it they were really gonna do it
she was gonna be like a spy or something
yeah no uh that was real it didn't get
very far
but
what confuses me is the de-aging about
May uh it depends on the circumstances
like I kind of
I kind of get it
for like
um
Tom Holland's Spider-Man
I think just bringing a somewhat younger
energy to the whole thing made sense
um I think it suited him better but like
I don't need it as an overall thing
um because like
gray-haired old woman is kind of the
that's that is Aunt May iconically so
yeah
let's see
oh wait who are we wishing
safe travels to oh the Pirates need to
get up at 3 30 in the morning for a trip
to NYC so I'm out of here ah we'll rest
well
and take care
nearly done with Harley Quinn really
enjoyed uh episode 8 of the latest
season I still I still haven't seen the
Valentine's special I completely forgot
that that was a thing
uh
catching up on Marvel stuff recently
really like Falcon and the Winter
Soldier what if and eternals I just
don't know if there's enough time to
bring everything together
well sorry hold on
excuse me
Falcon and Winter Soldier I I like
there's aspects of it I really like
there's other stuff that's not handled
very well
um unfortunately
um what if I I honestly really didn't
care for it at all by the time it was
done
eternals I liked a lot better than I
thought I would
I don't know if I ever need to watch it
again but it was pretty good
Dharma
remember for 15 months look at you go 50
months in zero regrets thank you
ah
does the AI Own It photons are free I
mean that'll be a question eventually
like if we ever get to a point I mean
well if we ever create the singularity
that'll be one thing but like if we ever
get to a point where the AI
doesn't require a prompt
like of its own accord
starts creating stuff and I don't mean
like how you wind it up and it just goes
forever that's still giving giving it a
prompt
but like if an AI ever started doing
that sort of stuff on its own there
would be an argument to be made
about
AI ownership potentially
I seem to recall it was recently ruled
that AI Works can't be copyrighted
that'll get challenged
I I don't
I don't doubt but
I I haven't been keeping super on top of
the legal end of it because
it's just so messy and copyright law is
one of the most mind-numbing things
to try and wrap your head around not uh
impenetrable
actually is usually fairly
understandable but
wow is it boring
uh
wasn't Sony planning a madame web film I
think that one is technically still in
development
happy International women's day ah thank
you she's the march here you're awesome
thanks so much Sammy I appreciate that
best thing about everything everywhere
all at once getting best ensembles that
they let James Hong do the majority of
the talking continuing to prove how
awesome
that uh not a generous he's ah yeah he
is pretty great
is genderflu still an applicable label
with you I'm a little unclear on that
yeah
yeah I'm still gender fluid that hasn't
changed oh hey Meg
nice to see you pop in
yeah I know I'm still gender fluid I
know I generally present feminine but
it's because
it's how I feel
most presentable if that makes sense
um
but yeah gender fluid has not stopped
being accurate
how much oh
thank you John vinyls how much of
Wednesday was basically Tim Burton going
dang I wish I'd made the owl house
I don't I don't think he wishes he made
the owl house it's too diverse
for him
um
Tim Burton
I enjoy some of his movies I do I don't
think he
cares about narrative
like at all I think his his
contributions are always the aesthetic
and like you match him to the right
material that can work really well I
think the only time he's honestly cared
about the narrative was big fish
every other time it's like ooh this is
something I can do something fun with
aesthetically I think that's the full
extent of what he thinks about anything
he's ever done and that's not an invalid
way to approach art
you can do that I just I think you're I
think you're attributing more uh more
intent to him than I would hahaha
let's see
have I ever been to Chicago for St
Patrick's Day I have never been to
Chicago at all
I do know about them dying the river
green the reason I know about them dying
the river green is because of a scene
and a line from The Fugitive
where at one point they're in Chicago
and it's
St Patrick's Day and you see the Green
River
and the U.S Marshals they're they're
just you know heading into a building
and they're just chatting like I really
love the fugitive that's a really great
movie that is not as remembered as it
should be but anyways
um one of them goes
Sammy let me ask you a question if they
can dye this River green today why don't
they diet blue the other 364 days out of
the year
laughs
I interrupted Shakespeare when I saw
this stream oh what's my favorite
Shakespeare play it's probably Midsummer
Night's Dream
I I like a fair amount of Shakespeare
overall
but that I mean I'd lean towards that
one because that's the one I want to be
in I really want to play puck
I really really do
I just came across something a bit scary
they're recreating thought images with
stable diffusion interpreting MRI
activity huh
that's odd
did you know that Calvin's dad was an IP
lawyer yes I did know that
I did indeed know that it's even
referenced at one point
uh in the comic
I'm wrong about Jumanji
okay
you are entitled to your opinion
will the Wednesday review be up soon I
mean if I do actually finish watching it
tonight I mean maybe it'll be up next
week
it's still a Batman A9 and returns I
returns
really kind of a mess
uh
fantastic Burton point on diversity uh
or flat lack thereof thank you oh you're
welcome
uh
why would you die a river the hell
because they can
Uggs with a box
Chad that was very generous I appreciate
that a sleigh
biggest anime crushed at the age of 10
20 30 40.
[Music]
hmm give me a second
uh
Ariel
Jessica Rabbit
30 30 30 30 30.
what would it have been a 30.
kusanagi and uh Scorpia there we go
it was my favorite character in Chicago
uh
ooh favorite character in Chicago
I really like Mama Morton she's a lot of
fun I enjoy the heck out of her and if
you get the right person to give it just
the right amount of
Swagger
um the lawyer whose name is suddenly
escaping me
Billy Billy Flynn
I think so but he can be really good but
he's tricky and if you balance him wrong
he's just a douche
um but he can be good Mama I think is
reliably usually my favorite
have I seen Bluey yes not all of it but
I have Bluey is great
I love Bluey
really it was mid-summer I was watching
that's cool
Omega back again thank you so very much
on Stan Lee I thought he was all about
the illusion of change yet he's the one
who pushed for the Spidey marriage in
the comic strip and later in the comics
the thing with Stan Lee
is
it's hard to know
so after he stopped doing a lot of the
actual writing so once we're into the
70s
it's hard to know what his core
philosophy and how much influence he had
or how much of it is people doing what
they thought he wanted because you'd get
stories of like people around the office
of Marvel's like oh well we have to do
this because it's what Stan wants and
it's something like he said idly in a
meeting once and then forgot about and
he doesn't actually care but they run
with it anyway so it's hard to know how
staunches the things that it was said
that he believed in how strongly he felt
a lot of them sometimes it's difficult
to parse
um
but it's worth remembering that a big
thing for Marvel initially from the 60s
I would say into the start of the 70s
was that their characters were Aging in
real time
Peter was in high school he was in
college he graduated
you know
um
the uh Fantastic Four the two of them
got married
you know characters were actually
getting older but then when they hit the
70s they
started instituting the rolling timeline
so it's not like
he never wanted any change but it's just
once enough things were established as
like this is what people expect then it
became difficult to ever move it forward
from there and that's not strictly to
understand Lee that's actually that's a
massive problem with DC as well
have I ever read the book version of The
Princess Bride I have it's quite good
it's an odd read but it's quite good
um
as much as he's great in The Fugitive
I'm still very bitter at Tommy Lee Jones
won the Oscar over Ray fines and
Schindler's List I mean fair enough
excuse me
uh
uh who is my biggest girl crush now in
2023 oh I don't know
uh
I
I don't know I don't keep track of
crushes anymore too much
would I play Mama Morton if I could I
I mean I love the character I'm not sure
I feel it particularly Affinity to play
it like
I could see myself doing the song like
for
a cabaret performance or something but
out of
I don't know
best entry point to DC animation start
with Batman the Animated Series yes and
then stop once the movies hit their new
52 inspired continuity
save yourself a lot of pain
awesome Geeks is my biggest girl crush
in 2023 oh my goodness Maureen thank you
55 A.D
uh
uh this oh and also again with a
correction this wasn't intentional but
service detail state of the art and use
of weapons have common characters oh
I did really like some of the characters
in surface detail
uh demycin especially he was great I I
really loved him I am dropping stuff
left and right sorry I lost my coaster
[Music]
um
have I seen the complaint about the race
swaps in the new Disney Peter Pan
um I saw that they existed I have not
looked into what people are actually
complaining about because it's the same
it's the same rage Merchants giving the
same
they're not worth my time and energy
ah
when your daughter gets a little older
and should she say she wants to read
something deep slash intense put her on
the animorph's track uh considering
content uh due to check but it's good I
I know what my kid reads and I know what
my kid watches and I she could handle
Animorphs
uh I'm pretty confident
I think I'd have a hard time selling it
to her like she's she's just a tough
sell on a lot of things she's reluctant
to try things for the first time rather
often but if he can get if he can get
your hooks into her she can she can
really really get into things and she
might get into that if I could ever talk
her into it it'd be tricky though am I
going to watch secret Invasion yeah
yeah I mean like I'm still sticking with
the MCU so
have I been invisible this whole time no
Carolyn never
uh see
the Discord yes I will get to the
Discord in a second I've got one more
um
Super Chat to hit and then I will do the
Discord
um
so John vinyls coming in once again
thank you very much for that Burton is
very much a Vibes director who mostly
helps realize other people's screen
plays while David Lynch and Guillermo
del Toro and Dana Terence are very
careful and meticulous about the kinds
of stories they want to tell yeah I'd
say that's fair
yeah I'd call that pretty accurate
okay the Discord reminder
the Council of Geeks Discord is a perk
of the Council of Geeks patreon
patreon.com Council of Geeks join now
and at the two door support your support
to your YouTube will get access to the
Discord you can chat with me and other
people including some of the people in
the chat with you right now just for two
dollars a month patreon.com
councilofgeeks
all right uh let's see
what is my go-to home-cooked dinner
um if I'm the one cooking
um honestly I'm liable just to throw
together pasta more often than not for
dinner I actually tend to get slightly
more creative with uh
uh with lunch because I have energy by
dinner I'm just like I just want
something easy
um having seen your leverage take What
shows have you never watched that you
have a nagging feeling you should oh
geez that is a list that
goes on forever there's a lot of stuff
that I either suspect I would like or
have seen like one or two episodes of
and been like I should watch more of
that like it's a lot
it's a lot I can't even like my my brain
is um
just kind of shutting down at the idea
of trying to think of all this stuff you
know whether it's
Merlin or you know leverage
um
heck cheers for that matter it's yeah
it's all over the place BoJack Horseman
still
there's a lot
uh what one Oscar win would you most
like to see this coming weekend I barely
remember the nominees
I would like to see everything
everywhere all at once win a bunch of
stuff and I'll leave it at that
see
hi I wouldn't be able to make the lie
but we'll catch up tomorrow oh okay
um how do you feel about the current
Trend in TV shows being shorter in terms
of the length of the overall series with
more serialized than episodic I miss
episodic television
it's one of the things that was really
fun about watching the episodes of
Leverage because those are fully
contained stories
I appreciate good serialized
storytelling when it's good it's great
but you know what's something that can't
ever happen to an episodic show
having a bad ending ruining the whole
thing
serialized is a high risk High reward
situation if you do it well then you
have a well laid out long-running
narrative that pays off at the end and
if you blow it if you pull a Game of
Thrones you get to the end and you
realize this nonsense is what it was all
building up to I can't even go back and
watch the old episodes again because
they were directly building into this
whereas an episodic show
you know the the ending can be garbage
but individual episodes because they're
Standalone will still work
I I tend to prefer more episodic TV
overall like again I appreciate
serialized TV but it's become a little
bit more of a thing than I would like
what's my favorite Standalone episode of
any TV show San Junipero
um what upcoming film or show am I
looking forward to the most probably
season two of Loki uh right now
yeah there isn't a ton I'm super stoked
for this here at least not that I'm
remembering off the top of my head
uh
you get to reshoot the Haunted Mansion
trailer what do you do well first thing
we dropped the uh the tag on joke at the
end
um and we just spook it up more we just
go more creepy
cut the jokes
after the front end jokes in the
beginning
scary the back end but not like jump
scares not like Dread and horror but
like
yep unsettling that's that's where I
would put it have I ever been to Salem
Massachusetts I have been it's lovely
and I'm hoping to go again in the not so
distant future hopefully with good
company if I'm very lucky
uh let's see do you think the rock Doug
black Adam's gray by refusing to keep
black Adam's ties to the Shazam Mythos
it feels like you want a Black Adam to
be an Iron Man scenario a lesser known
character becoming a face of a franchise
but failed to take into account that
unlike Iron Man Black Adam excuse me is
first and foremost a spin-off character
with heavy ties to the character he spun
off from because I still haven't seen
the Black Adam movie I don't feel
confident in
um taking a swing at that
um
because it's because I don't know how
well or badly it it did or didn't work
continuing the DC film questioning do
you think it would benefit the DCU films
to just have Barry Allen die and replace
him with Wally West instead of recasting
well yeah
yeah that would be a much cleaner a way
to resolve that
uh with Harry Potter being such a hot
button series Wizards being on the outs
do you think we should have a series
focusing on the arch enemy of wizards
that being barbarians
Harry Potter style Barbarian series
welcome to Barbarian school today we
will be through we will be throwing logs
as far as possible
and then
you should learn how to drink Mead
they're 12. they will learn how to drink
Mead
[Laughter]
I feel like a barbarian's version of
Harry Potter is just like all the
teachers are Hagrid
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh
I did see that there's another question
that just came in I won't be addressing
it on stream I may uh answer it in text
back in the Discord because the rule is
questions have to be in before the
stream starts so I am now back
in the mainstream I'm out of the Discord
I'm back in the Stream
do you think Mainline Disney and Pixar
animated films should focus more on
sequels or original projects I would
much prefer original projects
um but like some of the
some of the sequels have been good I
won't deny
uh
I need olives on my pizza I hope we can
all remain friends
I'll find a way to overlook it
I wish we could hang out it would be so
much fun oh
uh thank you Julia I appreciate that
what's my favorite way to cook pasta
al dente
I mean
there's really kind of only three ways
to cook it undercooked Al Dente and
overcooked
I just hope that Loki's season two
finally gets that Loki should be able to
really be physically gender fluid Loki
always has been way back in the Norse
mythology Loki spends time is both sexes
I just want them to firmly commit to
Sylvie being trans
like that Sylvie used you know Loki's
powers and abilities to become a woman
to be a woman
I mean she treats Loki like a dead name
I would like them to just canonically
commit to that
uh 255 A.D I will look at it in the
Discord and I will respond to it in the
Discord I am I am going to hold to the
granted they are arbitrary rules but
they're my arbitrary rules and I'm gonna
stick to them
was there ever a possibility of you
getting sucked into an MMO or children's
card game I mean I sucked into Magic the
Gathering back when I was in Middle
School
um
but
I probably I mean I part of the I very
consciously didn't take up World of
Warcraft because I'm I was pretty sure
it would devour my life
like I lost a lot of hours to Diablo 2.
World of Warcraft would have annihilated
my life
there we go
hey do you agree that people mocking
Southern and or rural American accents
is harmful because it leads to prejudice
then there were people who have those
accents
who are trying to make positive societal
changes they are dismissed or mocked
um
I don't think making fun of somebody's
accent in general is usually a super
great thing to do I'm not gonna say you
can never do it but
um
it's
it's one of those things that my gut
instinct is because sort of going after
anybody for anything that they can't
change about themselves you know be it
their age their body type a disability
their sexual orientation their accent to
me you shouldn't be making fun of of
them for that regardless I
don't know if I agree with the people
trying to make societal change being
dismissed because
I mean one of the things and granted
this is the perspective of a northern
northern New Englander who's
family came over on the goddamn stupid
ass Mayflower
um
you know and and my family stayed up
here the whole damn time
keeping in mind that this is my
perspective I feel like one of the
things that can be said
is that the southern mentality is a lot
more local and that's actually generally
true in more rural areas in general and
there's a lot of rural areas
in the uh in the south
so
I
the thing is I feel I don't feel like
having a Southern accent has prevented
people from getting a shot at a national
stage when they've gone for it and when
they're working locally you know other
people have the same accent so it's not
as much of an issue I don't know it's
it's hard for me to say but I do
I do things in general that
mocking an accent is a kind of a um for
me
best depiction most interesting use of
Amnesia in Media
um
memento
I mean there isn't too much interesting
too much else interesting it's done
maybe you could do it on stream anyway
my mother's going to the hospital
tomorrow I've given you a lot of money
uh
so 255 A.D
I will take a look at the question I
don't
super appreciate feeling like you're
trying to twist my arm on it like Just
for future reference
um
just because like yes you have but like
that's been
four things that's for the perks you get
through the patreon that's for the
addressing of questions here so it's not
um
I'm gonna try and say this as politely
as I can having supported me in the past
even going above and beyond what other
people normally do doesn't Grant you
access to me
beyond what I am willing to give
I will take a look at the question but
please don't
um
please don't try guilt or arm twist me
on that issue in the future
do you think it is inappropriate for
someone to have an intimate relationship
with a girl they grew up with even if
she's not technically your sister I
Revisited the book use of weapons after
my commission I was like
does Banks not realize that's
inappropriate
um
okay so you're talking a little bit
about it's a bit of a Trope the sort of
raised together but not actually related
turns to romance thing which
it's a weird gray area so
the short version is
yeah I think it's kind of inappropriate
the level of inappropriateness I think
varies depending on the nature of how
they grew up together because you know
there's just happening to grow up in the
same house together and then there's
literally behaving and being raised as
if you were siblings so there are
gradations of that but yeah the general
notion of like this is something that uh
I don't know if it actually comes up in
anime and manga a lot but the cliche is
that it does
um that there's always this you know
here's our young handsome male
protagonist and his adopted sister and
like they put so much emphasis on the
adopting you're like you're gonna hook
these two up aren't you and yeah there's
something there's something kind of
skeevy about it it feels like
it feels like wanting to indulge in a
fantasized
um taboo relationship without fully
going there and let me be clear in terms
of like
individuals in a private intimate
scenario doing role play I'm not gonna
King Shame you what as long as everyone
is consenting and knows full well
everything that's going on you role play
whatever scenarios you want to role play
between two consenting adults but
you know
when it shows up unexamined
and you know outside of things that seem
to understand that it's
a little gross that's the thing it's not
just that it happens it's that when it
happens it's unexamined this is
something that's actually been coming up
with me repeatedly lately and came up
with the last uh record that I did with
Jesse talking about Babylon 5.
sometimes the issue isn't that a thing
happens it's that a thing happens and
the narrative and or the writer isn't
examining it and doesn't seem to realize
that that's actually messed up because
it's okay to have messed up stuff but
it's when there's no commentary on the
messed up stuff and you're left going
wait did you think that was actually
okay to do
because it seems like you thought that
was okay to do
so okay I'm back in the chat now and I
am I am gonna Hardline on that I'm not
going back to the Discord tonight and we
are going to wrap it up in a little bit
will there be another watch stream for
the Oscars no no
um I've got my kiddo this weekend I'm
not gonna try and juggle all that
Listen To The River Song audios
featuring Eric Roberts it takes a while
for him to get back into the swing of it
but he's a lot more cunning here than he
was in 1996 that's not hard they didn't
know what they were doing with him in
1996.
I swear he was given different direction
for every scene he was in
see Adrian
I live in North Florida I don't have a
Southern accent I mean the people I know
who live in South don't have Southern
Accents either but to be fair they also
weren't raised there
most of them the ones who were were
raised in Florida and had money so you
know
that's a that's a whole other thing
best Eddie Murphy movie oh
I mean I'm partial to Trading Places I
say that being fully aware that some
parts of that have aged
horrifically bad
um
but I'm kind of drawing a blank
otherwise
foreign
as far as like ones of his that I
especially liked
I uh 255 A.D sorry I crossed the line I
accept your apology I accept your
apology
um be aware of her future though okay
cool
um
yeah
you're in Florida I'm so sorry yeah
I've got I've got some family that live
in Florida some of them I feel bad for
some of them I don't
there you go
also the river story also in the river
Story featuring Missy I love that it's
clearly early days for her and she's not
speaking in a Scottish accent yet oh
Nifty
uh but okay I am going to I'm gonna wrap
it up I think thank you everybody for
joining me
um and for just
spending a little time
I hope that you all have a great rest of
the week tomorrow I will be on Twitch in
the morning uh playing I believe hold on
let me get let me get the order of the
words correct here super lesbian animal
RPG that's what I'm playing tomorrow on
Twitch
don't ask because I don't really know
we're gonna find out together
um Saturday and I'll be
um
I will be
I will be streaming that again on Friday
oh see you mag thank you for stopping in
um
and then so Saturday's video here on the
channel is actually about Spider-Man and
Mary Jane and sort of in general issues
with comics and being unable to just
ever deal with certain scenarios or
certain changes and always resetting so
just my thoughts on that
um in general and
[Music]
um yeah I think that's about it coming
up
I mean there's there should be links in
the description of this for you know
other stuff Tick Tock and
Twitter and and whatnot
um yeah most most of the stuff I do is
link there
some of the stuff I do is is not linked
there but
if you know you probably know already
but uh in any case thank you very much
for joining me folks
what I really want you to remember
though
and I mean it
you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I am just running
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
mccavity